in ET the Extraterrestrial a lonely
Suburban boy named Elliot discovers a
friendly alien in the woods with whom he
soon forms an indelible psychokinetic
Bond it became the highest grossing
movie of its time received nine Academy
Award nominations and solidified
director Steven Spielberg as the premier
filmmaker of his generation meaning
Spielberg and screenwriter Melissa mat
had to at least entertain the notion of
an ET sequel together they wrote a
nine-page outline for et2 nocturnal
fears a movie very unlike the original
ET in that it was a sci-fi horror movie
that barely featur feed ET at all
apparently Spielberg quickly realized
that this was all a really really bad
idea as he once said at an American Film
Institute event sequels can be very
dangerous because they compromise Your
Truth as an artist I think a sequel to
ET would do nothing but Rob the original
of its virginity